hi i'm jana levin i'm a professor of
physics and astronomy at barnard college
of columbia university and today i've
been asked to explain black holes in
five levels of increasing complexity a
black hole might be different than you
imagine
to some extent it's a place and not a
thing
black holes play an important role in
the history of the universe
in sculpting galaxies that we live in
and possibly in the ultimate fate of the
universe
hi hi welcome tell me your name jude i
wanted to ask you if you have ever heard
of a black hole yeah i think that
they're scary and cool
because you can get sucked and get lost
forever
and get plopped out in a random place
it's like a big giant
black thingy so black holes you describe
them as huge the interesting thing about
black holes is they're hugely heavy but
they're actually physically really small
what really matters is the density do
you know what density is it's not weight
but it's how much of it is in it here
let me show you something i can ask how
heavy it is
i can also ask how big it is which is a
question about its volume if i make it
smaller
then
what's happening is it's becoming more
dense
so imagine i crushed this
really really small it would weigh the
same it would have the same mass but it
would be much more dense
how does it go that small if a star is
heavy enough to explode into supernova
what's left begins to collapse under its
own weight
and if that's heavy enough the core will
not be able to stop collapsing because
it no longer has the thermonuclear fuel
it's run out of fuel
and if it's run out of fuel it's no
longer shining and pushing outward and
without that it itself begins to go dark
and there's nothing fighting the
collapse anymore and that's when you
form a black hole so
if like the sun all collapsed on itself
it would form a black hole well that's a
really good question so interestingly
the sun itself isn't heavy enough so it
has to be heavy enough
that when it begins to collapse
it just overcomes all attempts to fight
it if you made something really dense
you would have to travel faster than the
speed of light
to actually escape that's 300 000
kilometers per second well it goes so
fast that there's it's all dark
so it goes so fast that it goes
completely dark any light that veers too
close will fall in will not be able to
make it back out again if a light is
shining from the sun near a black hole
buckle's not touching it
why does the light get pulled in why
does that happen because the black hole
is taking other stuff it is taking other
stuff but the funny question was like if
i wanted to move your chair you'd think
it was really strange if i didn't have
to come near you and actually grab the
chair and move it one of the things
einstein thought about is he
imagined
that
what the black hole is doing is it's
changing the shape
of space around it what do you think of
that idea
that's crazy isn't it crazy
and then einstein goes a step further
and thinks well what black holes must be
doing is curving the space so strongly
that even light gets caught sometimes
you can get light caught into a whole
orbit
literally the light going round and
round in an orbit so black hole it
doesn't attract light it moves the space
so that the curve is pointed towards it
that's right we've been talking for a
little while
about black holes what are you going to
walk away with in your impression of
what a black hole is it's kind of curved
in space
that are all coming to one
point everything that goes on those
curves changes directions to come in
and even light can't escape it nothing
can you said that very beautifully does
that
feel like a different
idea of a black hole than the one you
had before we spoke yeah a lot
[Music]
have you heard about black holes yes i
know it has a lot of mass
but it's very small
i know
that there are several theories about
the universe due to black holes
like around the universe and how it's
made so a lot of times stars are born
together in two star systems and when
they die if they're heavy enough they
will collapse under their own weight and
form a black hole so here you have a
black hole and a big fluffy star and
what will happen is it'll start to tear
apart its neighboring star
literally parts of the star will begin
to spill onto the black hole and
splatter on the black hole but let's say
both those stars formed black holes and
what these black holes do is they are
like mallets on a drum they create
literally waves in the shape of
space-time as they're moving so imagine
now it's on a drum how the drum ripples
depending on how the mallets are moving
you hear different sounds so effectively
these black holes as they get very close
together in the final stages of their
life together they're orbiting each
other
at hundreds of times a second it's just
really crazy event but it's happening in
complete darkness eventually they bobble
together and they merge and then they
ring out the space times going crazy
around them it's the storm in space-time
and they settle down to a quiet black
hole then those waves that they created
travel through the universe basically
undisturbed for a long time people
thought well even if black holes are out
there they're impossible to observe
and then they got very clever you might
wonder
how we could possibly hear black holes
that sounds crazy so i'm going to show
you but i'm going to need your help this
demo involves an electric guitar do you
play at all a little bit you want to do
the demo for me so the ligo instrument
electronically
records
the ringing of the shape of space with
this very complicated instrument it
stands for laser interferometric
gravitational wave observatory and the
design was incredibly difficult and they
didn't know if they would succeed i
think of the instrument as like the body
of the electric guitar and then they
take the readout of the motions of the
waves that they're recording just like
that guitar is recording the motions of
the waves on the string i just play it
like a little bit
and you can't hear anything
right you're not meant to hear an
electric guitar when it's not plugged in
what's happening is the guitar strings
are ringing
but so quietly
that we can't actually hear the sound
and this is like the gravitational waves
which are ringing the drum of space-time
but so quietly that they're not moving
the air and we're not hearing them so
now play and i'm going to turn the
volume up a little bit
[Music]
while i can't
actually hear the ringing of the strings
themselves i can hear the data
of the shape of the string recorded and
played through this amplifier and that's
kind of the idea behind the ligo
instrument how do you know that it's
like the black hole that's making that
sound and nothing else it's a great
question if i
didn't
see you playing the guitar i would
recognize
the sound of a guitar
and even if i'd never heard of a guitar
before i could figure out the
frequencies that the string was playing
i could tell how strongly it had been
plucked and i could tell the length of
it and where it was pinned down from the
harmonics of the string and i can tell
the different lengths of the strings
from the notes that they play so i can
actually reconstruct the instrument
that's playing it and it's very similar
to lego we can listen to the notes the
amplitude the harmonics and we can
deduce the size and shape of the objects
doing that and they're very massive and
they're very small and they have all the
markings of a black hole is there
anything that like gets affected on
earth because of those waves it's a
really good question only this
instrument and that's why it was so hard
to build and by the time it gets here
it's so weak
that it's only squeezing and stretching
space at like the fraction
of a nucleus over very large distances
has your understanding of black holes
changed over the course of our
conversation i knew there were waves for
like everything but i never
thought specifically oh yeah black holes
have
like waves i know more and less
i know what you mean
i'm jada it's nice to meet you nice to
meet you and where are you studying i'm
a senior at nyu i'm studying physics and
environmental studies what is your
impression of what a black hole is so
it's a
star that has collapsed it has so much
concentrated mass and gravity that
there's a point outside of the black
hole called the event horizon so once
you get past the event horizon nothing
not even light can escape from that so
that's a great definition and i want to
pick that apart a little bit so what you
described is just right stars when they
run out of thermonuclear fuel are going
to collapse under their own weight
it'll explode in a supernova it'll leave
a core and if the core itself is heavy
enough it will keep collapsing
it does as you say reach this point
where not even light can escape but the
amazing thing is it leaves that point
you called it rightly the event horizon
it leaves it behind kind of like an
archaeological record because the star
itself can no more sit at the event
horizon then it can race outward at the
speed of light so this core of the star
keeps collapsing and where it goes
nobody knows so in a weird way the black
hole isn't any more a crush of matter it
left it behind in its wake but the stuff
of the star is gone i've heard
of
short shield black holes which
is a black hole that is static a curved
black hole or a ker newman black hole
which is a black hole that rotates
but what makes a black hole
static versus rotating
and what's more common it turns out that
there are only three quantities that
define a black hole its electric charge
its mass and its spin so the most
general black hole can also spin
and it can also be electrically charged
whether or not they are has to do with
how they formed if a star collapses it
will likely be spinning when it
collapses and the remnant black hole
that forms will likely be
spinning a black hole of a certain mass
charge and spin
is
indistinguishable from any other black
hole with those same properties so in
some sense they're like fundamental
particles which makes them
absolutely exceptional for any other
astrophysical object have you heard the
stories about what happens inside a
black hole i remember that once you pass
the event horizon
space becomes time and time becomes
space in like a coordinate sense so from
the outside if you're an astronaut
you're watching your friend another
astronaut who going into the black hole
it's as though your times become rotated
relative to each other so the profound
thing is as an astronaut on the outside
looking at this round event horizon you
think of the center of black hole as a
point in space
but to the person who's fallen in it's
not a point in space at all it's a point
in time the singularity or the the end
of it all the crush in the center of a
black hole is in their future so they
can no more avoid the singularity then
you can avoid the next instant of time
coming so the death and the singularity
is inevitable although we don't really
think the singularity necessarily exists
i
sort of know what a singularity is
i
think of it as something
where
everything is compacted into one single
point it's a place where the laws of
physics don't exactly work out what did
you mean when you said that you don't
think the singularity really exists so
the singularity is definitely predicted
in einstein's general theory of
relativity and that's purely a theory of
space-time and in the theory of
space-time there is no question that a
singularity would form when the star
collapses catastrophically inside the
black hole now even when people talked
about singularities back in the 60s
they thought you know quantum mechanics
is part of the story of the whole of
physics it's not just gravity because if
we understand quantum gravity
we'll realize that singularity probably
doesn't ever actually form so since we
obviously have never been
to a black hole
um how do we know
for sure like
what happens
after you cross the event horizon or
what happens inside a black hole is it
just like inferred from the math
i would say to some extent we don't know
for sure what we have found is that the
mathematics is so unbelievably powerful
that we're able to disprove wrong ideas
just in pen and paper just very recently
within the past couple of years the
first ever
human procured image of a black hole
showed us what we expected to see of the
event horizon so jada after our
conversation today
what would you say a black hole is
something that i had never
thought of before is a black hole as
kind of a type of quantum fundamental
particle i've also learned how
the event horizon of a black hole kind
of hides a singularity the beauty of
being a student of something like black
holes is you never stop
having new impressions of what this
enigmatic phenomena is
so in a year i'll tell you what i
learned that's new awesome
[Music]
i'm claire and you're in graduate school
and you're getting your phd what what
year are you i'm a second year so i'm
measuring star formation histories in
the small and large magellanic clouds
does the large magellanic cloud have a
big black hole so
i think the prevailing wisdom for a
while was no but my answer honestly is
i'm not sure yeah and probably nobody is
have you heard a lot in your studies
about these supermassive black holes
that we think lurk in the centers of
very nearly every galaxy so i don't
study agn a lot but i do
have
a long term interest in black holes it's
one of the reasons i entered the field
i always was
curious about how a black hole of that
size
was able to form was it the result of
mergers between smaller black holes
ultimately creating
a gravitational well deep enough to
contract a
proteogenic disk for a whole galaxy or
man man what happened yeah i think it's
a really good question the only
mechanism that we know for sure can form
black holes as a collapse of very
massive stars so it's sensible to think
well maybe some very massive stars in a
young universe collapsed under their own
weight and then they merged and after
some time they got big enough but the
black holes from stars can be tens of
times the mass of the sun
maybe hundreds of times in the mass of
the sun if they merge to get to millions
and billions and if you just do the
simple arithmetic of how many years that
would take there aren't enough years in
the 14 billion years
of the universe's lifetime so they must
have come from somewhere else i am
at a loss
to think of
what could have possibly happened in
between the start of the universe and
the formation of our galaxy that could
create such a massive object
yeah i think that's right i think people
are really perplexed about how you make
something so big in such a short period
of time it's kind of funny the bigger
you make a black hole it seems maybe
counter-intuitive but the less dense the
material has to be out of which you make
it so you can out of something the
density almost of air
you can make a supermassive black hole
you can't make a star out of that but
weirdly if you skip the star phase
altogether it's conceivable that they
directly collapse and so there's a
suddenly a new way to make black holes
that nature is figured out we spend all
of our time when we learn about black
holes in school predominantly through
star collapse yeah i didn't even realize
that there was an alternate route to
creating a black hole there might be
many alternate routes it might be in the
very early universe that bubbles in
unusual phase transitions from very high
energy universe to a low energy universe
can make black holes like we haven't
really thought of the range of
possibilities and so there could also be
primordial black holes that are still
around that that also skipped the star
stage altogether that were formed really
in the very earliest phases and i think
the interesting thing is with you're
looking at like the large magellanic
cloud is to wonder if we're going to
merge
absolutely we thought the canonical
picture of the clouds was essentially
that they had formed with the milky way
maybe in its halo and had been in a
stable orbit for about a hubble time or
about 14 billion years young guns in the
field have thrown a wrench in that
theory that they've always been orbiting
and that perhaps they're on their first
orbit they're on an unstable orbit will
they join us can you tell us about
andromeda andromeda is part of the big
three in the local group the local group
being a group of galaxies that are not
expanding with the expansion of the
universe away from each other they're
trapped gravitationally by all friends
yes they're all friends and andromeda is
one of the few galaxies that is
traveling towards us and we are due for
a merger event at some point so given a
sufficiently low velocity we would just
have two big galaxies that for the most
part pass through each other pass by
each other but given a sufficiently high
velocity we will have some crazy black
hole interactions and some crazy star
interactions but when we do merge with
andromeda presumably our black holes
will emerge and andromeda indeed has a
very big black hole as well at its
center and then we'll have this
just gigantic
super massive yeah and
it's very possible that as you said the
collision won't be so severe that it'll
be very disruptive so our entire solar
system could stay intact
and here we would go with the sun and
all the other planets in orbit
around a new black hole they're kind of
misunderstood giants in a way
so i was curious have you heard anything
new or interesting in the field of black
holes that
will shape future discussions we work a
lot right now on thinking of black holes
as batteries
so a black hole that can take
like a giant magnet astronomical magnet
in the form of another collapsed star
like a neutron star and flip it around
so fast near the speed of light that it
actually creates an electronic circuit
out of this moving magnet and so that
the power that can come out of these
electronic circuits created by these
batteries can be tremendous you know i
know that at a certain point for our
civilization to become sufficiently
advanced to travel the cosmos beyond you
know the moon or mars we may have to be
able to harness the power of our sun
would it be similarly possible to
harness the power of a black hole like
you were mentioning to travel
it's a great question i once did a
calculation
of
using a black hole made out of the moon
and the strongest magnet we could find
on earth
to see if i could make an electronic
battery and
honestly you only get about enough
energy to power new york city but we
have to find one in our neighborhood
first yeah wouldn't it be my favorite
thing
so claire we've had this
pretty fascinating conversation about
supermassive black holes in particular
and after our discussion
what is it that has changed for you in
your perspective and what is it that
excites you so i think our discussion
kind of exposed a piece of black holes
that i don't think of often which is
that they're not just life takers
they're life-givers and they inform a
lot about not just how a galaxy is
destroyed or made but how it's shaped
and how it eventually you know
builds life
like ours
so maybe i have to give black holes a
little bit more props
[Music]
hi dan i'm so glad you could make it
what have you been working on with black
holes in the time since i've last seen
you there are a lot of aspects to black
holes the one that's kind of interested
me most lately is trying to understand
them from the point of view of
information how information is stored
and processed and recovered from black
holes
which turns out to be a really
interesting
perspective talk us through hawking's
initial
revolution that led to a lot of these
conversations about the information
around black holes hawking's
big insight was that he had to apply
both the rules of quantum mechanics and
the rules of gravity to really
understand how black holes behaved but
hawking
took a point of view where he brought
quantum mechanics into the game he
realized that if you took that into
account
that it's actually not quite true that
black holes are black that actually
things can escape from black holes so
what you're describing is the famous
hawking radiation where a black hole
cleverly kind of steals energy from the
quantum vacuum and radiates and then the
process evaporates and of course it's
caused a big kerfuffle because when the
black hole evaporates eventually that
event horizon is yanked up
and the question is is where did
everything go that had once fallen in a
way to think about hawking radiation is
to imagine that
pairs of particles and antiparticles are
appear out of the quantum vacuum
and the particle can escape the black
hole but the antiparticle falls in but
the particle and antiparticle are
repaired and
if the antiparticle really falls into
the black hole and is destroyed at the
singularity that poor particle outside
the black hole
has lost his partner it also violates
the rules of quantum mechanics if you
have two particles that are entangled
that has to be preserved now to be clear
nobody disputes that black holes will
quantum radiate that hawking radiation
is a solid prediction the black holes
should in fact evaporate that's not
disputed right that's right it would be
wonderful if we could have some
experimental evidence for this if we
could really
build a black hole in the lab and and
test to see whether it behaves this way
but i think there is hope that we'll be
able to detect some of these effects
either indirectly by looking at black
holes out in the universe
or also maybe indirectly in the
laboratory by looking at systems which
aren't black holes but which radiate in
kind of similar ways there's this domain
of black holes in astrophysics where we
see stars collapse and we know that they
exist and there's whole observational
astronomy around them and then there's
this domain that we're talking about
where as you said black holes are so
special because they're kind of guiding
us in the right direction
to understand the very nature of reality
and that makes them really unusually
special one of the things i wanted to
draw out is that
we talk about the fundamental forces of
nature so there's the matter forces
and then the outlier is gravity we've
quantized all the matter forces in a way
that we're rather comfortable with
gravity keeps resisting quantization of
gravity itself
and now we're thinking in a way that
you're describing that well maybe it's
only the quantum forces altogether the
pursuit of quantum gravity has
taken us to places we never expected to
be i think what's exciting about physics
about theoretical physics
that you start following a thread you
start developing a chain of logic
and you never know where it's going to
end up do you think there's ever a hope
that the kind of information
that you think about the quantum gravity
aspects of the universe that you think
about
whether it will pan out or not
will ever be viably observed in these
astronomical pursuits of the event
horizon it's a real challenge
but
astronomical observations have gotten so
fantastically precise
and there is some hope that if you
looked at things like two black holes
merging
each black hole comes in with its own
event horizon
but then when the black holes merge
there's a very complicated process where
these two event horizons merge and
oscillate and vibrate and then settle
down into a single event horizon for the
final black hole there is some hope that
if we can make sufficiently detailed
observations of this process
if we could really see the way the event
horizon is behaving as it settles down
to this final state
that maybe that could reveal some of
these quantum effects that we've been
talking about it is amazing in the
numerical simulations of two black holes
merging you really see the event
horizons bubble around and we were
talking earlier about how really black
holes are flawless they don't tolerate
those kinds of imperfections and so you
can so quickly watch
the system ring away
that misshapen
merger and it comes out in the
gravitational waves which is literally
the ripples in the shape of space-time
until it settles down and then it's
utterly flawless again it's really
happens fast it's quite amazing yeah
it's a spectacular process
in some sense
black holes aren't anything anymore
they're just empty
curved space times and nothing is there
how would you possibly make one
and then it becomes why are there so
many and where are they all
being a black hole scientist means each
question leads to more questions we know
more and more but we also see how much
more there is to understand
i hope you've learned something about
black holes thank you so much for
watching
[Music]
you